Jonathan Edwards est décrit par d'innombrables personnes comme l'un des théologiens les plus influents du XVIIIe siècle.
Et parmi ses œuvres majeures, outre sa célèbre prédication « Entre les mains d'un dieu en colère », nous avons son livre « L'histoire de l'œuvre de la rédemption ».
Dans cet ouvrage, Edwards examine l'œuvre de rachat de Dieu depuis la chute de l'homme jusqu'à la fin du monde.
Jonathan Edwards achève son ouvrage en concluant que tout ce qui compose l'histoire humaine est lié à l'œuvre de la rédemption de Jésus-Christ et que rien ne peut contrecarrer le travail de Dieu.
Dans sa sagesse, Dieu permet que tout ce qui se passe serve littéralement à faire progresser ce plan éternel.
Et cette conviction de l'importance de l'œuvre de la rédemption n'était pas propre à Edwards.
De nombreux théologiens et des réformateurs la partageaient aussi.
Ils ont eux aussi écrit pour marteler cette grande et importante œuvre de Dieu dans son monde.
C'est donc avec raison qu'ils ont compris que plus ils contempleraient la sagesse éternelle du Dieu trine,
plus leur cœur se réjouirait dans une adoration joyeuse, véritable et authentique de Jésus-Christ.
Fort d'un cœur enflammé par l'œuvre de la rédemption de Dieu,
ces théologiens ont cherché à comprendre et à systématiser bibliquement
le rôle des trois personnes de la Trinité dans l'œuvre de la rédemption.
Ainsi, des puritains comme John Owen, John Flavel,
ou des théologiens comme Francis Suretin, John Murray,
ont parlé de la rédemption comme étant décrétés par le Père de toute éternité,
accomplis par le Fils dans l'histoire
et appliqués par le Saint-Esprit dans le cœur des pécheurs.
En d'autres thèmes, pour ces hommes,
le salut des pécheurs sauvés par grâce est une œuvre trinitaire
dont l'origine remonte aux temps anciens,
dans le cœur même de l'unique vrai Dieu,
Père, Fils et Esprit.
C'est dans ce sens que cette rencontre entre le Christ
et le Docteur d'Israël nous paraît importante.
C'est l'endroit où notre Seigneur ne sait plus
à ouvrir la fenêtre de la sagesse infinie de Dieu.
En le faisant, le Christ nous donne de contempler
la beauté et l'efficace souveraineté
de l'œuvre de Dieu dans la rédemption.
Frères et sœurs,
il nous faudra veiller à ce que cet échange théologique
entre Jésus et Nicodème ne nous fasse pas perdre de vue un point central.
Car s'il y a une chose à retenir pour nous à ce stade,
c'est que le salut est une œuvre surnaturelle du Dieu trinitaire,
Père, Fils et Saint-Esprit.
Aussi, les pères de l'Église ont préféré utiliser une maxime très célèbre
pour parler de cette œuvre et des actions communes de la Trinité.
Ils disent que les œuvres externes de la Trinité sont indivises.
Il y a ainsi entre les trois personnes de la Trinité
ce qui est appelé la circumcision.
Ce terme technique décrit le jeu commun
dans lequel s'expriment l'harmonie et l'amour
réciproque entre les trois personnes de la Trinité.
Nous devons donc faire tous nos efforts
pour ne pas séparer ce que Dieu a uni.
Nous pouvons distinguer les actions de chaque personne de la Trinité dans le salut,
mais au grand jamais, au grand jamais,
nous ne devons les séparer.
Nous allons donc nous approcher de ce texte
en respectant les emphases de notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Par la vérité qu'il expose,
il magnifie l'œuvre de Dieu
et dévoile ce qui était pourtant clair
dès l'Ancien Testament.
Mes frères et sœurs,
malheureusement, cette œuvre de l'Esprit de Dieu,
dont le salut est souvent mal comprise,
et même dans nos milieux évangéliques,
et en disant cela,
nous ne doutons pas de la sincérité de nos frères et sœurs.
Toutefois, nous pouvons constater
le mauvais enseignement tiré de ce passage.
Et l'une des raisons
qui poussent à un tel enseignement
est le reste du péché
qui continue de nous envelopper si vite
et qui a tendance à obscurcir notre intelligence.
Ce péché remanant
et nous empêche d'apprécier avec clarté
ces vérités glorieuses
qui parfois brisent encore
et encore notre orgueil.
Alors, ma prière pour nous ce matin,
mes frères et sœurs,
c'est que nous puissions,
en traversant cette péricope,
être en prière
au pied de notre Seigneur,
le suppliant,
afin que son Saint-Esprit
illumine ce texte
pour faire comprendre
à chacun de nous
ce qu'il veut dire
et de nous en délecter
de sa révélation.
Nous le savons bien,
nous ne pouvons rien faire sans lui.
Et avant de nous plonger
dans l'exposé de ce passage,
je voudrais que vous reteniez
cette vérité centrale
que nous allons considérer
tout au long de cette prédication.
C'est celle de l'œuvre souveraine
de l'Esprit de Dieu
comme unique réponse
de Christ
au cœur troublé du pécheur.
L'œuvre souveraine
de l'Esprit de Dieu
comme unique réponse
de Christ
au cœur troublé
du pécheur.
Il va donc consister pour nous
à aborder en première partie
de cette prédication
le cœur troublé du pécheur.
Puis en seconde partie,
en deuxième partie,
nous allons aborder
la nécessité de naître
d'en haut.
Et pour terminer,
nous verrons
l'œuvre de l'Esprit
dans le cœur du pécheur
à travers l'histoire.
Sans plus tarder,
abordons la première partie,
le cœur troublé du pécheur.
Je vous invite à relier
avec moi les versets 1 à 2.
« Mais il y a eu un homme
d'entre les pharisiens
nommé Nicodème,
un chef des Juifs
qui vient, lui,
auprès de Jésus de nuit
et lui dit,
« Rabbi,
nous savons que tu es
un docteur
venu de Dieu,
car personne ne peut faire
ces miracles
que tu fais
si Dieu n'est avec lui. »
Nicodème est décrit
comme quelqu'un de très important
dans le système religieux juif.
C'est un enseignant,
mais pas qu'un.
Il est le docteur d'Israël.
Pas un,
mais le docteur d'Israël.
Cela veut dire qu'en termes
de connaissance des enseignements
de l'Ancien Testament,
il sut passer de loin
ses pères.
L'on devait se référer
à lui pour toutes les questions
en matière de théologie
et de piété.
À lui tout seul,
il était la référence
de ce système
judaïque
et pharisaïque.
Mais voilà,
sa venue de nuit
vers Jésus
cache quelque chose
de profond
que seul Dieu
qui sonde le cœur
des hommes connaît.
Non, Seigneur,
Jésus le sait
et n'hésite pas
à aller droit au but
avec Nicodème.
Vous remarquerez,
Nicodème ne pose
aucune question.
Toutefois,
Jésus lui fait
une déclaration
bien surprenante.
Jésus connaissait
le cœur du pécheur.
Au chapitre 2,
nous,
Jean nous dit
que plusieurs cruent
au nom de Jésus
quand il était
à Capernaum
en voyant ces miracles.
Mais Jésus
ne se fiait point
à eux
car il les connaissait
tous
et il n'avait pas
besoin qu'on lui
rende témoignage
d'aucun homme.
Jésus savait
lui-même
ce qui était
dans le cœur
de l'homme.
Le cœur troublé
du pécheur Nicodème
était comme
un livre ouvert
devant le Seigneur Jésus.
Notre cœur
l'est de même
devant notre Dieu
car nul créature
n'est caché
devant lui
mais tout est à nu
et à découvert
aux yeux de celui
à qui nous devons
rendre compte.
Évoué 4,
verset 13.
Alors,
qu'est-ce que Jésus
pouvait voir
au fond du cœur
du fils d'Adam
venu
de nuit
vers lui?
Il pouvait voir
un cœur apeuré
et un cœur
troublé.
Et ce cœur
troublé
a une origine.
C'est celui
hérité
des conséquences
du péché
d'Adam
dans le jardin
d'Éden.
Rappelez-vous,
après avoir
mangé
du fruit
de l'arbre
dont Dieu
les avait défendus,
Adam et Ève
se cachèrent.
Ils le firent
après avoir
entendu
la parole
de Dieu
lorsqu'il les cherchait.
Depuis ce jour,
tous les enfants
d'Adam,
sans exception,
sont les imitateurs
de leur père.
Ils confirment
ce que disent
les proverbes.
Le méchant
prend la fuite
sans qu'on
le poursuive.
Proverbe 28.
Et en effet,
au brissement
d'une simple feuille,
le méchant
prend la fuite
devant Dieu.
Mes frères et sœurs,
derrière cette
observance rigoureuse
de la loi de Dieu,
cette admiration
sans pareil
de ses pères,
ainsi qu'une position
de chef religieux,
Nicodème n'arrivait
pas à calmer
les tempêtes
de sa conscience.
Toutes ses tentatives
pour le faire
avaient
littéralement
échoué.
John Piper dit
La religion
constitue
l'un des principaux
moyens
par lesquels
l'homme
dissimule
sa réticence
à abandonner
son autosuffisance.
Et de ce fait,
l'homme
ne fonde pas
ses espoirs
sur la grâce
et méritée
de Dieu.
principaux moyens
par lesquels
les hommes
dissimulent
très souvent
leur réticence
à abandonner
leur autosuffisance
et ne veulent pas
fonder leur espoir
sur la grâce
et méritée
de Dieu.
Et c'est ce que
Nicodème,
le pharisien,
avait fait
toute sa vie.
Et c'est ce que
de nombreuses personnes
aujourd'hui
continuent
d'imiter.
Même la théologie
la plus précise,
c'est qu'il y a
une bonne chose.
Les honneurs
religieux
et les louanges
ne sauraient
nous sauver.
La seule raison,
c'est que
le pécheur
est sauvé
par la foi seule.
Cette foi seule
est la cause
instrumentale
de notre salut.
Et cette foi
qui sauve
est celle
qui se repose
en Jésus-Christ
seul
et en aucun autre.
et sans la nouvelle naissance,
sans naître
de nouveau,
d'en haut,
il est impossible
de parler
de cette foi
salvatrice.
Notre capacité
à nous cacher
derrière des systèmes
bien établis
tels que
des traditions
d'église,
des confessions
de foi
ou même
des églises
en bonne santé
peut cacher
notre refus
de nous confier
au seul moyen
que Dieu nous a donné
pour nous sauver.
Et si c'était
le cas
pour le docteur
d'Israël,
cela peut être
le cas
pour nous aussi.
Nous devons
veiller
à cela.
Toutefois,
Nicodème,
le pécheur inquiet,
n'hésite pas
à reconnaître
que Jésus
vient de Dieu
et que
ses miracles
l'attestent.
Il reconnaît
comme un maître
dont Dieu
approuve
les voies.
Il est important
ici que
nous comprenions
l'utilité
des miracles
de Jésus
dans son ministère.
Il avait
pour but
de rendre témoignage
de son enseignement
et de confirmer
son identité
de Christ,
le Messie
tant attendu
d'Israël,
le fils
du Dieu
vivant.
C'est ce dont
Nicodème témoigne
en disant
nous savons
que tu es
un docteur
venu de Dieu
car personne
ne peut faire
ces miracles
que tu fais
si Dieu
n'est avec lui.
Oui,
le docteur
d'Israël
n'avait jamais
vu de miracle
dans toute sa carrière.
Il était
bluffé
par les œuvres
de Jésus-Christ
car jamais
il n'avait
vu ou entendu
dire que quelqu'un
ait ouvert
les yeux
d'un aveugné.
Jean 9,
verset 32.
Et bien
que lui
et ses amis
pharisiens
ne pouvaient
nier
ces miracles
en privé,
il ne voulait
jamais
les approuver
en public.
Ils étaient
à la fois
admiratifs
de ce prédicateur
et jaloux
de ce que Dieu
faisait au travers
de son ministère.
Jésus
était
une grande
menace
pour leur autorité.
car là
où ses pharisiens
tenaient le peuple
par un joug
pesant,
Jésus
lui aimait
ce peuple
et pleurait
sur lui.
Jérusalem,
qui tue
les prophètes
et qui lapide
ceux qui te sont
envoyés,
combien de fois
ai-je voulu
rassembler tes enfants
comme une poule
rassemble ses poussins
sous ses ailes
et vous ne l'avez
pas voulu.
Jésus
était un homme
radicalement
différent
d'eux
et cela
accentuait
leur haine
contre lui.
Aujourd'hui encore,
Jésus
est haï
sans cause.
Il ne laisse
personne
indifférent.
Toutefois,
chers auditeurs,
je me dois
de vous le dire.
de ce que vous
ferez
du Jésus
biblique
dépendra
votre éternité.
Soyez-en sûrs,
votre destination
finale
dépendra
de ce que vous
faites
de ce Jésus
qui est
condamné
dans cette parole,
dans la parole
du Dieu
vivant.
Allez-vous
mettre
votre confiance
en lui
ou allez-vous
rejoindre
les rangs
des pharisiens
qui le jalousaient
en privé
et qui le haïssaient
en public?
Je vous en supplie,
je vous en supplie,
réfléchissez
à cette question.
Elle est
d'un poids
éternel
pour notre âme,
pour le vôtre,
pour la mienne.
Le cœur
troublé
de Nicodème
l'avait bien compris
et de ce fait,
il est venu
de nuit
à Jésus.
Qu'en sera-t-il
de vous
aujourd'hui
à l'écoute
de ce message,
de cette prédication?
Nicodème
est le docteur
d'Israël
au cœur
troublé
qui est venu
à la rencontre
de Jésus,
le véritable
docteur
d'Israël
qui seul,
seul
pouvait le guérir.
Continuons
à suivre
Nicodème
dans cette discussion
théologique
avec Jésus
afin d'aborder
notre deuxième
partie.
qui est la nécessité
de la nouvelle
naissance.
Relisons
les versets 3 à 6.
Jésus lui répond
dit,
En vérité,
en vérité,
je te le dis,
si un homme
ne naît de nouveau,
il ne peut voir
le royaume de Dieu.
Nicodème lui dit,
comment un homme
peut-il naître
quand il est vieux?
Peut-il rentrer
dans le sein
de sa mère
et naître?
Jésus répondit,
En vérité,
en vérité,
je te le dis,
si un homme
est né
d'eau et d'esprit,
il ne peut
entrer dans
le royaume
de Dieu.
Ce qui est né
de la chair
est chair
et ce qui est né
de l'esprit
est esprit.
Un homme
peut ignorer
beaucoup de choses
en religion
et pourtant
être sauvé.
Mais être ignorant
de ce que Jésus
enseigne
sur les sujets
tels que
la nouvelle naissance
et le salut
par la foi
au Fils de Dieu seul,
c'est être
sur la voie large
qui mène
à la destruction.
Le serviteur
de Christ
fera bien
de s'y familiariser
profondément.
La nouvelle naissance
n'est donc pas
un sujet marginal.
Elle est central.
l'éternité
est en jeu
lorsque nous parlons
de la nouvelle naissance.
Alors,
essayons de le faire
en résumant
le propos
du Seigneur Jésus
en une question.
Existe-t-il
une condition
pour rentrer au ciel?
Si oui,
comment la remplir?
À moins que l'on
ne prenne pas Jésus
au sérieux,
la réponse est oui.
Il existe
belle et bien
une condition
pour aller au ciel
et jouir
de la présence
bénie de Dieu
éternellement.
Et si cette condition
n'est pas remplie,
vous ne rentrerez pas
dans le royaume
de Dieu.
Vous ne le verrez
même pas.
Vous ne pourrez
y participer
ni même
le posséder.
vous ne pourrez
vous targuer
de chrétien
sur la terre,
mais Christ
dans le ciel
ne vous aura
jamais connu.
Vous pourrez
imiter
les comportements
des croyants,
mais jamais
Christ ne vous
appellera
sa brébie.
Car pour cela,
il faut que
vous naissiez
de nouveau.
S'il existe
une nouvelle naissance
chez un pécheur,
alors il y a
nécessairement
justification,
adoption,
sanctification
et glorification.
Toutefois,
si la nouvelle naissance
est absente,
alors il n'y aura
jamais trace
d'une seule
once de bénédiction
rédemptrice
de Christ
chez ce pécheur.
Jésus
désire tellement
être au clair
sur l'importance
de sa vérité,
qu'il la formule
de deux manières
pour l'exprimer.
Comme un enseignant
qui se soucie
de communiquer
avec exactitude
et clarté
son savoir
à ses étudiants.
Si un homme
ne naît de nouveau,
il ne peut voir
le royaume de Dieu.
Si un homme
ne naît
d'eau et d'esprit,
il ne peut entrer
dans le royaume
de Dieu.
Mais frères et sœurs,
cette doctrine
de la nouvelle naissance
est si extraordinaire
que même Nicodème,
ce grand docteur,
ne la comprend pas.
Toutefois,
je vous prie
de ne pas prendre
Nicodème de haut.
Car même aujourd'hui,
de nombreux enfants
de Dieu
lui ressemblent
dans cette ignorance.
Soyons donc
pleins d'humilité
en le regardant
maintenant
qu'il est stupéfait
devant les déclarations
du Seigneur Jésus.
aussi,
peut-être
quelqu'un
pourrait me dire
comment remplir
cette condition?
Maintenant
que tu nous as dit
que Jésus enseigne
qu'il y a
une condition
à remplir
pour entrer
dans le royaume
de Dieu,
dis-nous
comment faire?
Nous nous leverons
de nos sièges
et nous irons
faire cette chose
si capitale
pour le salut
de notre âme.
Mes chers,
aucune œuvre
que vous puissiez faire
ne suffira
à vous faire naître
de nouveau.
Pensez à l'œuvre
la plus héroïque
qui vous passera
en tête
et révettez-la
des plus belles motivations.
Je vous l'assure
avec insistance,
elle ne vous suffira
jamais
pour naître
d'en haut.
Car les enfants
de Dieu
sont nés
non du sang,
ni de la volonté
de la chair,
de l'homme,
mais de Dieu.
Jean 1,
verset 13.
La nouvelle naissance
est une œuvre
impossible à réaliser
pour l'homme.
Car de la même manière
que vous ne pouvez
rentrer dans le ventre
de votre mère
et renaître,
c'est ainsi
que vous ne pouvez
naître d'en haut
par vous-même.
Il vous faut donc
naître d'eau
et d'esprit.
Alors,
de quoi parle Jésus
en disant
qu'il faut
que vous naissiez
de nouveau
ou que vous naissiez
d'eau et d'esprit?
Puisque Jésus
reproche à Nicodème
d'être le docteur
d'Israël
et de ne pas savoir
ces choses,
il nous faut regarder
à la Bible
de Nicodème
à cette époque.
nous trouvons un indice
dans le livre
d'Ézéchiel
au chapitre 36
verset 19 à 27.
Je vous invite
à ouvrir
Ézéchiel
chapitre 36
verset 19 à 27.
Et pendant que vous ouvrez
Ézéchiel 36,
je vous donne
le contexte
de ce passage
avant que nous
puissions le lire
ensemble.
Dieu avait puni
Israël
pour son infidélité
et les avait dispersés
parmi les nations.
Toutefois,
Dieu n'avait pas fini
avec son peuple.
Il n'en avait pas fini
avec eux du tout.
Il leur promettait
un jour
de faire une œuvre
surnaturelle
en eux.
Lisons Ézéchiel 36
du verset 19 à 27.
Je les ai dispersés
parmi les nations.
Et ils ont été répandus
en divers pays.
Je les ai jugés
selon leurs conduites
et selon leurs œuvres.
Et ils sont arrivés
chez les nations.
Où ils allaient
et ils ont profané
mon saint nom.
En sorte qu'on disait
d'eux,
c'est le peuple
de l'Éternel,
c'est de son pays
qu'ils sont sortis.
Vous voyez,
jugé par Dieu,
envoyé en exil.
Dans cet exil,
le peuple continue
son infidélité
et son idolâtrie.
Dieu parle
à cause
de son saint nom.
Il leur parle.
Je sanctifierai
mon grand nom
qui a été profané
parmi les nations
que vous avez profanées
au milieu d'elles.
Et les nations
sauront que je suis
l'Éternel,
dit le Seigneur
l'Éternel.
Quand je serai sanctifié
par vous
sous leurs yeux,
je vous retirerai
d'entre les nations
et je vous rassemblerai
de tous les pays
et je vous ramènerai
dans votre pays.
Blasphémant le nom
de Dieu en exil,
Dieu,
à cause de son seul nom,
à cause de son honneur,
à cause de son grand nom,
veut faire une œuvre
surnaturelle en eux.
Et regardez
ce qu'il dit
qu'il fera.
Je répandrai
sur vous
une eau pure,
une eau pure
et vous serez purifiés.
Je vous purifierai
de toutes vos souillus
et de toutes vos idoles.
Je vous donnerai
un cœur nouveau
et je mettrai en vous
un esprit nouveau.
J'ôterai de votre corps
le cœur de pierre
et je vous donnerai
un cœur de chair,
une chirurgie incroyable,
surnaturelle,
par la même
même faite de Dieu.
Je mettrai
mon esprit en vous
et je ferai en sorte
que vous suiviez
mes ordonnances
et que vous observiez
pratiquer mes lois.
N'est de nouveau
pour obéir.
pour pratiquer
les lois de Dieu.
Voilà ce à quoi
notre Seigneur
faisait référence.
Dieu avait promis
de déverser une eau
qui purifie l'âme
de tous les souillus,
de tous les idoles
et de changer
le cœur de pierre
du pécheur
en lui donnant
un cœur de chair,
un cœur
qui sache répondre
à Dieu.
Il avait promis
de faire don
de son esprit
au pécheur.
Dieu avait promis
de donner
son Saint-Esprit.
Nicodème
était le docteur
d'Israël
et il devait
donc savoir
ces choses.
Il n'avait
aucune excuse
car c'est un oeuvre
de l'histoire
de la rédemption
de Dieu.
Nous aussi,
nous n'avons
aucune excuse
de passer à côté
de cette réalité,
de cette vérité.
Nous devons la considérer
comme un joyau précieux
que Dieu nous a donné
de contempler.
cette nouvelle naissance
n'est donc pas seulement
une réforme
ou une amélioration
ou un changement moral
ou une altération
extérieure de la vie.
Elle est beaucoup
plus profonde
que ça.
Beaucoup plus profonde
que ça,
mes frères et soeurs.
Le pasteur réformé,
Mathieu Henry,
l'exprime de cette manière.
Écoutons-le.
C'est un changement
complet du cœur,
de la volonté
et du karaté.
C'est une résurrection.
C'est une nouvelle création.
C'est un passage
de la mort à la vie.
C'est l'implantation
dans nos corps,
dans nos cœurs, pardon,
mort d'un nouveau principe
d'en haut.
C'est la création
d'une nouvelle créature
avec une nouvelle nature,
de nouvelles habitudes de vie,
de nouveaux goûts,
de nouveaux désirs,
de nouveaux appétits,
de nouveaux jugements,
de nouvelles opinions,
de nouvelles espérances
et de nouvelles craintes.
Tout cela
et rien de moins
est impliqué
lorsque notre Seigneur déclare
que nous avons tous besoin
d'une nouvelle naissance.
Et ce changement de cœur
est rendu absolument nécessaire
au salut
à cause de l'état de corruption
dans lequel nous sommes tous nés
sans exception.
Ce qui est né
de la chair
est chair.
Notre nature
est entièrement déchue.
L'esprit Chanel
est inimitié
contre Dieu.
Nous venons au monde
sans foi,
sans amour,
ni crainte envers Dieu.
Nous n'avons
aucune inclination
naturelle
à le servir
ou à l'obéir.
et aucun plaisir naturel
à faire sa volonté.
Laissé à lui-même,
aucun enfant d'Adam
ne se tournerait jamais
vers Dieu.
Aucun.
La description la plus juste
du changement
dont nous avons tous besoin
pour devenir
de véritables chrétiens,
c'est l'expression
nouvelle naissance.
En d'autres termes,
Jésus disait à Nicodème
au cœur troublé,
tu sais,
Nicodème,
pour être israélite,
il faut naître
de chair.
Mais pour être
enfant d'Abraham,
fils de Dieu,
il faut naître
de l'esprit.
Ainsi,
puisqu'il faut
que nous naissions
de nouveau,
et puisque cette nouvelle naissance
ne peut venir
par nos œuvres,
alors il faut
que nous supplions
le Saint-Esprit
de Dieu
d'opérer cette œuvre
de nouvelle naissance
dans le cœur
des pécheurs.
Il faut que nous allions
devant le trône de grâce,
supplier,
implorer Dieu
de sauver les pécheurs.
Par eux-mêmes,
ils peuvent se sauver.
Mais Dieu nous a donné
la prière
pour supplier,
pour implorer,
pour que nous puissions
voir des hommes
sortis des tombeaux
pour venir à la vie.
Si vous avez mis
toute votre espérance
en Christ,
dans les promesses
de Dieu,
si vous portez
des fruits dignes
de la repentance,
alors il y a certainement
une œuvre surnaturelle
de Dieu
qui a changé
votre cœur
de pierre
en cœur de chair.
Vous avez
de nouveaux désirs,
de nouvelles affections
pour Christ.
Et là,
je ne parle pas
de perfection,
mais de direction.
Vous faites
un pas en avant,
quatre pas en arrière,
mais vous continuez
à courir.
C'est votre seul espoir
pour le saisir
car il s'est saisi
de vous.
Rappelez-vous
la parabole
du salmiste.
L'Éternel
a fermé
les pas
de l'homme.
Il prend plaisir
à sa voix.
Et si cet homme
tombe,
il n'est pas
déraciné,
terrassé.
l'Éternel
lui tend
la main
car cette belle œuvre
qu'il a
commencée en vous,
il va l'achever.
Quelle espérance,
quelle promesse.
Même pas à une main,
nous devons la saisir.
À deux bras,
il le met
dans nos cœurs,
jalousement.
Et si vous ne connaissez
pas Christ,
il n'est pas
trop tard.
Il n'est pas
Si vous vous dites,
assurement,
je ne suis pas né
de nouveau.
Tout ce que tu décris
est étranger
à moi.
Alors,
je vous en supplie,
courez à Christ.
Criez à lui
pour qu'il vous sauve.
Je ne peux le faire
à votre place.
L'Orique ne peut
le faire à votre place.
Le pasteur David
ne peut le faire
à votre place.
Nous pouvons tous
nous agénouer,
suppliez Dieu
de le faire.
C'est une œuvre
surnaturelle de Dieu.
Confiez-vous
en ses mains
percées
à cause de vos péchés.
Il vous tiendra.
Et Christ vous assure
que son Père aussi,
certainement,
vous tiendra
entre ses mains.
Le Père,
le Fils
vous tiennent.
il est venu,
non pas
pour les bien portants,
mais pour ceux
qui sont malades.
Alors,
malade,
va à ton sauveur,
va à ton docteur,
va te faire guérir.
Allez de nuit
à lui
comme Nicodème
si vous êtes intimidés.
Christ ne vous mettra pas
dehors.
Nous l'avons entendu
dans une prière.
Il vous donnera
un cœur nouveau,
pardonnera vos péchés
et vous assurera
l'héritage
avec les saints
dans son royaume.
Et si j'ai une telle assurance
en sa capacité
de sauver,
même le cœur
le plus endurci,
c'est parce que
cette œuvre
que le Saint-Esprit
applique au cœur
est une œuvre
souveraine
et unilatérale
du Dieu trinitaire.
Allons le constater
dans cette troisième
et dernière partie
intitulée
« L'œuvre de Dieu
dans le cœur du pécheur
au travers de l'histoire ».
En relisant
les versets 7 à 10
« Ne t'étonnes pas
que je t'ai dit
il faut que vous
naissiez de nouveau.
Le vent souffre
où il veut
et tu en entends
le bruit.
Tu en entends
le bruit, pardon.
Mais tu ne sais
d'où il vient
ni où il va.
Il en est ainsi
de tout homme
qui est né
de l'Esprit.
Nicodème lui dit
« Comment cela
peut-il se faire
? »
Jésus lui répondit
« Tu es le docteur
d'Israël
et tu ne sais pas
ces choses. »
Les Écritures
enseignent clairement
que cette doctrine
de la nouvelle naissance
est une œuvre
monergistique
de l'Esprit
de Dieu.
C'est-à-dire
que seul
Dieu
donne la nouvelle
naissance.
Il ne collabore
avec personne
ou n'attend
aucun signal
de qui que ce soit.
Il ne demande
conseil
à aucune autre
créature.
Cette nouvelle
naissance
procède
de sa souveraineté
et de son
propre dessein.
Pour être convaincu,
pour en être convaincu,
revenons au texte
d'Ézéchiel 36
que nous avons lu
tout à l'heure.
Je vous prie
de suivre
avec attention
celui qui s'exprime
ici.
Ézéchiel 36
verset 25
Je,
l'Éternel,
reprendrai
sur vous
une eau pure
et vous serez
purifiés.
Je,
l'Éternel,
vous purifierai
de toutes vos
sueurs
et de toutes vos
idoles.
Verset 26
Je,
l'Éternel,
notre Dieu,
vous donnerai
un cœur nouveau.
Je,
l'Éternel,
mettrai en vous
un esprit nouveau.
J'enterai
l'Éternel
de votre corps,
le cœur de pierre
et je,
l'Éternel,
vous donnerai
un cœur de chair.
Verset 27
Je,
l'Éternel,
mettrai mon esprit
en vous.
Je ferai en sorte
que vous suiviez
mes ordonnances
et que vous observiez
pratiquer mes lois.
Avez-vous remarqué
le pronom personnel
« je » ?
Ce pronom personnel
fait référence
à Dieu,
l'Éternel.
C'est lui
qui s'est dit
qu'il allait
faire tout ça.
Il s'est engagé
à être l'auteur
de la nouvelle naissance.
Le prophète Jonas
l'affirmait
de cette manière.
Le salut
vient de l'Éternel.
Quelle richesse
dans cette déclaration
puissante.
C'est donc souverainement
que des hommes
naissent de nouveau
et sont unis
à Christ
pour la vie éternelle.
Et c'est selon
le bon plaisir de Dieu
il lui plaît
d'agir ainsi.
Ne m'est-il pas permis
de faire de mon bien
ce que je veux ?
Matthieu 20
verset 15
Et l'illustration
familière
tirée du vent
appuie cette vérité
de la souveraineté
de Dieu
dans la nouvelle naissance.
Cette œuvre
échappe
à notre entendement
et est mystérieuse
comme le mystère
qu'on l'enceve
autour du vent.
Jesse White
dit
Non Seigneur
Jésus dit à Nicodème
qu'il en est exactement
de même
pour les opérations
de l'esprit.
Lorsque l'évangile
est prêché
le Saint-Esprit
utilise la parole
de Dieu
pour donner la vie
aux pécheurs.
Les choses
qu'il rejetait
deviennent des évidences
dignes d'être acceptées.
Ce qui était flou
finit par prendre
sens à ses yeux.
Et c'est bien cela
l'œuvre de l'esprit.
Dieu se plaît
à faire briller
ainsi la lumière
dans nos cœurs
pour faire resplendir
la connaissance
de la gloire de Dieu
sur la face de Christ.
Il lui plaît
d'agir de la sorte.
dans ce dernier message
pour la conférence
des bergers
qui n'a pas pu prêcher
mais qui l'a écrit.
Docteur John MacArthur
a dit
« La vie spirituelle
est une œuvre créatrice
opérée par Dieu.
Si nous sommes fidèles
à proclamer la vérité,
notre mission
s'arrête là.
Dieu seul
peut sauver une âme.
peut sauver une âme. »
Je le répète
une nouvelle fois.
Le mystère
est beaucoup
trop grand
pour nous.
Mais lorsque
nous voyons
chez un homme
des fruits produits
par un changement
manifeste
du cœur
et de la vie,
nous n'avons pas
le droit
de douter
de la réalité
des opérations
de l'esprit.
Nous n'avons pas
le droit
de douter
de la réalité
de l'opération
de l'esprit
de Dieu
en cette personne.
Mais lorsque
nous ne les voyons
pas
chez une personne,
il n'y a
aucune raison
de s'hasarder
à parler
de nouvelle naissance.
Aucune raison.
C'est de la présomption.
Mes frères et sœurs,
l'œuvre
de l'esprit
de Dieu
donne la vie
aux morts
et elle ne doit
pas être vue
comme seulement
une réalité
du Nouveau Testament.
mais comme une œuvre
que l'esprit fait
depuis la chute
dans le cœur
des pécheurs.
Vous pourrez me dire
« Attends, Christian,
tu veux nous dire
que Adam,
Ève,
Abraham,
Isaac,
Jacob,
Élie,
Élisée,
Moïse,
Josué,
David,
les prophètes
et tous les croyants
de l'Ancien Testament,
eux aussi
devaient naître
de nouveaux.
La réponse
est un grand
héritantissant.
Oui,
ils devaient
eux aussi
naître de nouveaux.
La nouvelle naissance
n'est pas optionnelle
et Jésus l'a dit.
Il faut naître
de nouveaux.
Et vous savez quoi ?
Ils sont tous
nés de nouveaux
sans exception.
Il est bon
que nous puissions
voir au moins
deux raisons
pour lesquelles
la nouvelle naissance
était nécessaire
pour les saints
de l'Ancien Testament
comme elle est nécessaire
aussi pour nous.
La première raison
est liée
à leur nature
corrompue,
la nature
corrompue
de l'homme.
Et cette corruption
a commencé
avec la chute
dans le jardin
d'Éden.
Adam ayant chuté,
sa nature,
donc la nôtre,
a subi
la corruption
que nous observons
jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
le témoignage
des Écritures
est sans appel.
Sans appel.
Triste
et sans appel.
En Genèse 6,
verset 5,
juste avant
le déluge,
il est dit,
l'Éternel
vit que la méchanceté
des hommes
était grande
sur la terre
et que toutes
les pensées
de leur cœur
se portaient
chaque jour
uniquement
vers le mal.
Genèse 8,
verset 21,
après le déluge,
il est dit,
l'Éternel sentit
une odeur
agréable
et l'Éternel
dit en son cœur,
je ne maudirai
plus la terre
à cause de l'homme
parce que les pensées
du cœur
de l'homme
sont mauvaises
dès sa jeunesse.
Somme 14,
verset 2 à 3,
l'Éternel
du haut des cieux
regarde les fils
de l'homme
pour voir s'il y a
quelqu'un
qui soit intelligent,
qui cherche Dieu.
Tous sont égarés,
tous sont pervertis,
il n'y a aucun
qui fasse le bien,
même pas un seul.
Jérémie 13,
verset 23,
un autre pire,
un petit changer sa peau,
un léopat,
ses tâches,
de même pourriez-vous
faire le bien,
vous qui êtes accoutubi
à faire le mal.
Terminons avec
la confession
du prophète
Esaïe.
Nous sommes tous
des impus
et toute notre
justice,
toutes nos oeuvres
sont comme
des vêtements
souillés.
Nous sommes tous
flétris
comme une feuille
et nos crimes
nous emportent
comme le vent.
Esaïe 64,
6.
Notre cœur méchant,
nos bonnes oeuvres,
sans nouvelle naissance,
voilà le résultat.
Tout ce que nous avons lu
nous montre
que la nécessité
d'une naissance
d'en haut
a toujours été
d'actualité
depuis l'entrée
du péché
dans ce monde.
Aussi bien
les mauvaises oeuvres
que les bonnes
mettent en claire évidence
notre dépravation,
il fallait
qu'eux aussi
naissent de nouveau.
Par la désobéissance,
le péché
fit éruption
dans le monde
et donna la mort
à tous les hommes.
Par la nouvelle naissance,
le Saint-Esprit
fait une intrusion
massive
dans le cœur
du pécheur
et donne la vie
aux morts.
La seconde raison
est que
le concept biblique
de la nouvelle naissance
trouve son origine
même dans l'Ancien Testament.
Rappelez-vous,
Jésus pousse Nicodème
à regarder
dans le livre
saint de Yahweh.
Le Saint-Esprit
avait inspiré
les prophètes
sur cette réalité
de la nouvelle naissance.
Jérémie 31
au verset 33
Mais voici
l'alliance
que je ferai
avec la maison d'Israël.
Après ce jour-là,
dit l'Éternel,
je mettrai ma loi
au dédant d'eux,
je l'écrirai
dans leur cœur
et je serai leur Dieu
et ils seront
mon peuple
la plus grande
des bénédictions.
Jérémie 32
du verset 39
à 40
Je leur donnerai
un même cœur
et une même voix
afin qu'ils me craignent
toujours
pour leur bonheur
et celui
de leurs enfants
après eux.
Je traiterai
avec eux
une alliance éternelle.
Je ne me détournerai
plus d'eux,
je les ferai
du bien.
Je mettrai ma crainte
dans leur cœur
afin qu'ils ne s'éloignent
pas de moi.
C'est le langage
même de la nouvelle création.
À partir d'une masse
corrompue,
Dieu se fait
des vases d'honneur
utiles pour son service.
Ézéchiel 11
du verset 19
à 20
Je leur donnerai
un même cœur
et je mettrai
en vous
un esprit nouveau.
J'enterai de leur corps
le cœur de pied
et je leur donnerai
un cœur de chair
afin qu'ils suivent
mes ordonnances
et qu'ils observent
et pratiquent mes lois.
Ils seront mon peuple
et je serai leur Dieu.
Quelle déclaration
puissante de Dieu.
Mes frères et sœurs
Depuis la chute,
le Saint-Esprit
n'a cessé
de dispenser
les bénédictions
de la rédemption
de Christ
jusqu'à ce jour.
Il a appliqué
l'œuvre de Christ
à chaque pécheur
sauvé par grâce.
Sans cette œuvre
massive de l'Esprit,
Abraham n'aurait jamais
reçu le nom
d'ami de Yahweh.
Moïse ne serait pas
reconnu
comme le prophète
du Très-Haut.
David n'aurait jamais
porté le témoignage
d'être l'homme
selon le cœur de Dieu.
La nouvelle naissance
est le début
de la vie.
Sans l'application
de cette œuvre
de l'Esprit
à nos cœurs,
tous les hommes
mouraient
dans leur péché.
Tous les hommes
sans exception
mouraient
dans leur péché.
Alors,
frères et sœurs,
pour conclure,
j'aimerais
qu'on se rappelle
de ce que Jésus
met en évidence
dans cette discussion
théologique.
Il y rend clair
la gloire bénie
du Dieu trinitaire,
exposant ainsi
la doctrine
de la nouvelle naissance.
Cette nouvelle naissance
est comme un fil
que Dieu,
se plaît,
a déployé
depuis la chute
en passant
par Nicodème
jusqu'à nous
aujourd'hui.
En suivant ce fil,
nous ne manquerons
pas de contempler
l'immensité
d'un Dieu
qui se révèle
dans toute sa splendeur,
dans toute sa majesté,
dans toute sa puissance,
dans toute sa sagesse,
dans toute sa grandeur,
dans toute sa fidélité,
dans toutes ses promesses
et surtout,
par son Christ,
par son Fils bien-aimé.
par le Fils du Dieu vivant,
par le Seigneur de gloire,
par celui qui rend possible
cette nouvelle naissance
pour nous.
Christ,
notre Rédempteur,
notre Souverain Sacrificateur,
Christ,
notre Dieu.
Et comme nous l'avons dit
en introduction,
que nous ne devons pas
séparer les œuvres externes
de la Trinité,
nous affirmons
dans cette conclusion aussi
qu'il ne faut pas non plus
séparer le Christ
de ses bienfaits.
La nouvelle naissance,
on est le joyau
qui découle de l'œuvre
de Christ à la croix.
Elle vient des mains percées
du Seigneur de l'Église
et appliquées
par l'Esprit du Christ
à ses élus
pour la seule gloire,
la seule gloire
de Dieu le Père.
C'est pour cette raison
que le Dieu Trinité seul
est digne
de notre adoration
et de notre émerveillement.
J'ai eu l'impression
de notre émerveillement.
que le Dieu Trinité seul
est en train de se
faire de la croix
et de notre émerveillement.
J'ai eu l'impression
de notre émerveillement.